bonjour bienvenue chez ico nutrisse
première ferme d'insectes comestibles de
france six mois alors dans cette pièce
on élève des grillons pour
l'alimentation humaine donc dans ces
bacs
on a recréé un écosystème qui permet aux
grillons de se développer
de la manière la plus saine possible et
on va les nourrir avec une alimentation
100 % issus de la culture biologique et
donc ce qui est vraiment fascinant la
production d'insectes ses come back
comme celui ci va contenir 40 me grillon
ce qui va représenter un équivalent
protéique l'équivalent de 1000 portion
de viande les insectes une excellente
alternative aux protéines animales
parce que les protéines d'insectes dont
contenir tous les acides aminés
essentiels et le gros avantage des
insectes c'est que leur production va
avoir un très faible impact sur
l'environnement
pour vous donner un chiffre un élevage
d'insectes va rejeter ce enfants moins
de gaz à effet de serre qu'un élevage
devient de plastique
[Musique]
or ici on est dans la pièce de
croissance des ténébrions donc on peut
le voir c'est un élevage verticale donc
on va pouvoir élever les insectes sur 10
niveaux ce qui permet d'avoir un très
faible encombrement au sol
donc ce qui est vraiment intéressant
dans ce type d'élevage c'est que dans
une pièce comme celle ci qui fait
environ 50 mètres carrés on va pouvoir
produire une tonne par mois de l'arbre
donc on a vraiment besoin d'un espace au
sol qui est beaucoup plus faible d'autre
part les larves aimait être élevée avec
une forte densité
donc on peut à la fois combinés les
logiques de bien-être animal et les
logiques de production de nutriments
donc le ténébrions molitor est un
insecte qui va avoir quatre différents
stades donc le stade adulte ou c'est un
petit scarabée
ensuite ce scarabée va prendre des oeufs
sur les zones ont éclos on va avoir une
petite larme et ensuite on a une étape
intermédiaire qui comme le cocon la
chrysalide qui s'appelle la nymphe chez
celle ténébrions et donc nous chez micro
nutrisse ont produit la larve qui est
aussi appelée vers de farine est en fait
cette la restaurer beaucoup d'énergie
pour la métamorphose
donc c'est ce qui explique qu'elle est
très riche en protéines
un minéraux en oméga 3 parce qu'elle a
besoin d'énergie pour
se métamorphoser
[Musique]
m
une fois qu'ils sont déshydratés on peut
les utiliser tel quel comme ingrédient
sinon on peut en broyant ces insectes
entier réaliser une poudre qui va
permettre d'être utilisé dans des
aliments plus nutritionnels comme par
exemple ses pattes qui grâce à la poudre
d'insectes vont contenir 20 % de
protéines et on a du coup des pâtes
riche en protéines et on n'a pas besoin
de rajouter de viande ou de poisson pour
avoir un plat équilibré
on va avoir des produits apéritifs ou
les insectes sont aromatisés prêt à
déguster
on va avoir des chocolats ou vraiment
les insectes sont utilisés sur le dessus
pour pouvoir découvrir les insectes
comestibles de manière gourmande et des
barres énergétiques qui sont riches en
protéines
les minéraux donc c'est idéal pour le
sport soit en préparation des défis
sportifs ou soit pour la récupération
notre défi ça va être de proposer des
produits gourmands et gourmets aux
consommateurs occidentaux qui ont peu
l'habitude de manger des insectes mais
il ya déjà deux milliards d'êtres
humains qui mangent les insectes un
petit peu partout autour du monde
[Musique]